der internationale frauentag
2022 ist ein tag an dem frauen mitten in
europa aus ihren häusern gepumpt werden
mit ihren kindern auf der flucht sind
mütter und großmütter um ihre söhne
bangen das leid der menschen in der
ukraine geht weiter auch am tag 13 der
westen steht zusammen die usa und
großbritannien wollen alle importe von
öl und gas aus russland stoppen
deutschland und frankreich bemühen china
um einfluss auf putin zu nehmen und der
ukrainische präsident die lenski fleht
um hilfe in einen emotionalen appell vor
dem britischen unterhaus heute abend
putins krieg wer kann noch vermitteln
unser thema heute in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
guten abend und ganz herzlich willkommen
aus berlin nicht auf in meine gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist lila melnik sie
ist leiterin des deutsch ukrainischen
forschungsnetzwerkes am institut für
europäische politik und moderatorin des
podcasts ukraine nemo und herzlich
willkommen micro hat ari er ist direktor
des mc arthur institut für china studies
merrick
zugeschaltet ist uns tim guldimann
schweizer diplomat und
politikwissenschaftler botschafter in
berlin und 2014 ukraine beauftragter
während der osze präsidentschaft der
schweiz und herzlich willkommen frank
umbach forschungsdirektor für
sicherheitspolitik an der universität
bonn und berater auch der nato zur
energiesicherheit form einig es ist tag
13 es ist eine menge passiert wieder
heute darauf gehen wir noch ein aber an
diesem tag was sind ihre größten sorgen
weiterhin
ich glaube auch was positiv ist dass wir
schon erlebt haben dass die ukraine
einen großen widerstand leistet und wir
bis heute haben auch festgestellt dass
die russische armee keinen großen
städten eingenommen hat darunter auch
herr sonne im süden der ukraine und auch
die ukrainische regierung hat noch die
kontrolle über die stadt das heißt über
die versorgung der stadt aber den größte
sorgen wenn ich jetzt zu sorgen über
gehe dann dass dieser krieg dauern wird
das wir haben ich glaube in der ukraine
hoffen sehr dass das in ein paar tagen
das ende dass wir das ende des krieges
sehen und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
wir im westen wirklich auf diesen langen
atem uns schon darauf einstellen können
und dass wir
so einen druck auf russland aufbauen
können und hoffen sie dann eher auf die
diplomatie noch irgendwie das gespräch
etwas bringe oder sagen sie auch wie
präsident selensky wir brauchen einfach
die militärische hilfe um diesen krieg
zu gewinnen
diplomatische mittel sind nur ein teil
die zu der konfliktlösung beitragen
können aber die ukraine braucht heute
die militärische hilfe
das geht in erster linie darum den
himmel in der ukraine zu verteidigen das
ist die größte schwachstelle der ukraine
und der wsg der ukrainische präsident
weiß ganz genau dass russland alles
dafür machen wird um einfach die städte
zu bombardieren und jetzt ist die
ukraine nicht in der lage so richtig
dagegen was zu machen und hier ist schon
sehr wichtig dass der westen ganz genau
prüft wie erst möglich wäre überhaupt
die ukraine in dem bereich zu
unterstützen sei es durch mögliche auch
militärflugzeuge oder durch andere
möglichkeiten wir haben dazu eine
nachricht dass polen jetzt
militärflugzeuge zur verfügung stellen
will darüber reden wir gleich jetzt
bleiben wir noch mal eben bei diesem
thema der der diplomatie rotary heute
gab es ein gespräch von bundeskanzler
scholz präsident makro und dem
chinesischen staatspräsidenten chipping
wie bewerten sie das die tatsache dass
die drei überhaupt eine stunde
gesprochen haben und was ist dabei
herausgekommen ist zunächst einmal dass
wir eine klare große internationale
dimension dieses konfliktes ist nicht
nur ein lokal begrenzter
auseinandersetzung der ukraine sondern
hier geht es um große strukturelle
machtfragen die auch im hintergrund
natürlich zentral sind dem ist richtig
dass europa und die bundesregierung an
regierung versuchen alle möglichen
kanäle auszuschöpfen und möglicherweise
zu einer besseren humanitären situation
waffenstillstand und ähnlichem zu kommen
gleichzeitig ist auch klar dass china in
diesem konflikt auch schon positionen
bezogen hat und sich an vielen stellen
recht klar neben russland stellt und
insofern ist das ein versuch der maximal
darauf ausgerichtet sein kann wenige
fortschritte und ein etwas klareres
positionieren in peking zu sehen ich
würde mir nicht davon versprechen und
erwarten dass hier wirklich mit ihm fing
der partei- und staatschef
systeme sind systematisch auf putin
einwirken kann er den konflikt zu
beenden als er das nicht eine wirkt aber
glauben sie denn wir sind das ist die
haltung sich ändern könnte dafür ist es
im moment noch zu früh ich glaube der
druck auf die russische wirtschaft und
die weltweiten wirtschaftlichen folgen
das ist das thema was sie wirklich
interessiert
da kann natürlich wenn der konflikt wie
rummenigge sagte lange andauert auch die
position picken sich noch deutlich auf
weichen aber stand jetzt ist das nicht
der fall die usa haben heute ein
deutliches zeichen gesetzt herum bach
sie haben gesagt die stoppen öl und
gasimporte aus russland großbritannien
will bis ende des jahres nachziehen was
bedeutet das dann was bedeutet es wenn
die usa jetzt so klar oder präsident
biden das heute nachmittag ja so klar
formuliert hat
es ist ja seit länger in der diskussion
ob wir die sogenannte blut
nämlich die finanzierung des guten
regierens wir haben in der vergangenheit
mit unseren steuermitteln für die
energieimporte auch die aufrüstung
bezahlt und willst ein und finanzieren
letztendlich natürlich auch die invasion
und alle begleiterscheinungen die damit
verbunden sind
die russland hat vor ein paar jahren
seine ölexporte richtung usa dramatisch
ausgebaut das war deswegen auch möglich
weil die usa gleichzeitig sanktionen
gegen venezuela verlassen hatte und dass
wir nicht das öl aus venezuela das
sogenannte schweröl ist in erster linie
nur in amerikanischen raffinerien weiter
verarbeitet worden dadurch sind
kapazitäten frei geworden das hat auch
russland genutzt vielleicht auch mit
klick eine gewisse abhängigkeit der
amerikaner von russland herzustellen wie
auch wenn sie nicht vergleichbar ist mit
jener europas und das war bis vor kurzem
schien das nicht möglich zu sein einen
solchen öl stoppt zu machen weil die
beiden administrationen innenpolitisch
ohnehin wegen hoher energiepreise
innenpolitisch und von den republikanern
stark kritisiert in der diskussion stand
jetzt haben sich aber in der tat beide
parteien im kongress dazu durchgerungen
diese ölimporte von russland lahmzulegen
das ist ein ganz ganz deutliches
politisches signal und hat nicht
unwesentlich noch zusätzliche negative
wirtschaftliche auswirkungen auf
russland wie sie auch schon kurzfristig
dann spüren werden sie sind wir gespannt
der guldimann ich würde gern mit ihnen
nochmal darüber sprechen der westen ist
sicher so einig wie haben es jetzt
gesehen russland ist ja immer weiter
isoliert die rolle spielen dass darüber
sprechen wir noch weiter aber sehen sie
denn überhaupt noch irgendeine basis für
eine diplomatische lösung
müssen aufpassen dass hier die
diplomatie nicht überschätzen die profis
nur die weichen für eine verständigung
und eine verständigung ist nur möglich
wenn die position sie auch zu lassen im
moment lässt die russische position
keine verständigung zu solange sie auf
regime change in kiel rausgehen auf eine
bedingungslose kapitulation
ob da irgendetwas in bewegung kommt
hängt weniger von irgendwelchen
diplomatischen versuchen aus ich meine
jetzt insbesondere was wir gehört haben
von china oder von anderen staatschefs
die versuchen darauf einzuwirken sondern
in erster linie darum ob einerseits
militärische erfolg der bis jetzt aus
bleibt irgendwie
es moskau erlaubt weiterhin eine harte
position zu haben und das hängt
natürlich auch mit den wirtschaftlichen
folgen der sanktionen zusammen also
stand heute will ich seinen diplomatie
funktioniert nicht was wir machen muss
ist den druck erhöhen und schauen ob sie
irgendwelche spielräume öffnen in der
russischen position und erst dann wäre
es möglich zu schauen das könnte
unterstützt werden für eine
verständigung
fromm einig es gibt aber ja weiter die
gesprächsbereitschaft auch von der
ukraine dass sie sagen wir sind bereit
zu sprechen am donnerstag wollen die
beiden außenminister miteinander
sprechen also gibt es da schon noch eine
chance wo sie sagen der gute mann dann
eigentlich ist ja die basis nicht mehr
da auch für die diplomatie sehen sie da
doch eine möglichkeit
wir wissen zum beispiel dass es gab
schon auf ein ganz anderer ebene auch
gespräche wurde die humanitäre korridore
vereinbart wurden die ukraine war immer
für für die gespräche ich glaube der
ukrainische präsident hat auch in dem
russischen vorgeschlagen sich zu treffen
allerdings wird das immer
verneint und
der russische präsident möchte sich auch
nicht mit dem koreanischen treffen aber
ich glaube was wichtig in der diplomatie
ist dass wir die diplomatie auch durch
diese militärischer oder dass wir nicht
die diplomatie weg von dem militär
betrachten in diesem konflikt man kann
jetzt
die ukraine hat jetzt eine sehr starke
position
wir müssen wirklich sagen wo ich glaube
ich persönlich bin keine militärexperten
aber 13 tage ja wir hatten ich glaube
die meisten von uns haben gedacht der
erste tag wird kommen und am nächsten
tag wird vielleicht schon geärgert und
jetzt 13 tage und keinen großen städten
wurden eingenommen august an bis heute
verweigert zum beispiel ihre getöteten
soldaten nach russland zu transportieren
nach ukrainischen angaben dass es über
10.000 schon die gestorben sind und
verhandlungen darüber möchte ruft dann
gar nicht führen zugang all diese
soldaten müssen jetzt in der ukraine
bleiben und jung trainer ist
verpflichtet nach der genfer abkommen
auch das alles richtig zu machen und sie
richtig schon zu behandeln ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob gross oder auch
kapazitäten dafür hat und ich glaube
jetzt mit blick darauf dass die und
trainer schon eine sehr starke position
hat
wichtig ist diese position weiterhin zu
stärken und nicht zu erlauben zum
beispiel durch diese ziel wieder durch
verschiedene bau war die man die
zivilbevölkerung als mittel sozusagen zu
nutzen weiß ich glaube russland jetzt
versucht zu machen zu zeigen so wir
zeigen das leid und vielleicht können
wir dadurch die ukraine zu beeinflussen
aber die zusage sich von flugkorridoren
wurde ja auch nicht einigen nur in einem
fall herum was sie wollten aber da
direkt noch was zu sagen nicht richtig
verstanden habe
ja ich glaube wir müssen uns ein
bisschen einordnen noch stärker die
gespräche sind wirklich laufen im moment
nur um die schaffung der humanitären
korridor und rumäne hat völlig recht
russland partie teilweise gar nicht
eingehalten die vorschläge die menschen
nach weißrussland oder russland zu
bringen ist völlig glaube ich völlig
absurd und musste natürlich
zurückgewiesen werden wir sprechen noch
nicht mal eigentlich über gespräche über
einen waffenstillstand auch wenn das von
der ukrainischen verhandlungsseite immer
wieder angesprochen worden ist russland
hat bisher absolut keine bereitschaft
gezeigt auch nur einen waffenstillstand
und sei es auch nur für paar tage
irgendwo einzurichten die
militäroperationen der einkesselung von
sharp kauf von tief gehen weiter auch
logistische vorbereitungen für einen
großangriff auf schief gehen weiter
russland verschafft sich damit auch noch
sozusagen etwas etwas zeit das ist
glaube ich sollte man nicht übersehen
und es gibt rein militärisch teile
vielleicht nicht ganz den optimismus von
frau wenig obwohl ich selber
anders als andere den den widerstand in
der bevölkerung auch der streit setzte
auch eine vorbereitung auf eine realität
führung ja vorausgesagt hatte aber wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass in einer
richtung tut den recht behalten hat und
das macht den unterschied auch zu den
georgien krieg noch mal deutlich nämlich
dass er mit der vermeintlichen
nuklearstrom noch einmal unterstrichen
hat das was man was wir jetzt an
sicherheitsexperten des eskalation story
nanz bezeichnen und damit ein
abschreckungseffekt auf die nato sich
nicht mit eigenen truppen auch nicht
durch die schaffung
eines eines luft korridors in
irgendeiner weise militärisch dort zu
intervenieren
im georgienkrieg was viele vergessen
haben war die konstellation zunächst
ähnlich es gab eine erhöhung der
bereitschaft der nuklear streitkräfte
mit dem signal an den westen an die usa
sich nicht weiter in diesen konflikten
irgendeiner weise zu involvieren
wir hatten dann ein vormarsch ähnlich
wie wir das in kiew hatten über zig
kilometer marschierten damals die
russischen streitkräfte auf tablets die
hauptstadt von georg hinzu um sie
einzunehmen und dann passierte etwas das
plötzlich diese streitkräfte anhielten
und umkehrt und der grund dafür war
nicht irgendein diplomatischer erfolg
sondern es war die nackte drohungen der
usa mit marschflugkörpern diesen
vormarsch militärisch aus recht zu
erhalten
und damit sozusagen die russische
erhöhung dieser nuklear bereitschaft und
damit auch dieser nuklearer abschreckung
strom nicht anzunehmen
und das sozusagen hat diesen vormarsch
aufrecht erhalten und nur das ist
sozusagen die voraussetzung gewesen dass
heute georgien als unabhängiger staat
überhaupt noch existieren weil ansonsten
wäre die plätze eingenommen worden und
dann werde georgien heute ein
vasallenstaat
russlands genauso großer person das ist
eben der unterschied in der nach wie vor
haben er und das ist ja auch der dieses
wenn man den osten noch mal in dieser
lesung globalen konflikt sie haben
soeben gesagt dass es eben nicht nur
einen konflikt zwischen russland und
ukraine ist dann geht es ja auch immer
um augenhöhe das ist ja das was für
putin so wichtig ist und da kommt doch
dann china auch wieder ins spiel oder
nicht wir haben in peking am vierten
februar diesen jahres eine gemeinsame
erklärung zwischen russland und china
gelesen und die in der folge auch weiter
bestätigt worden ist in der substanz und
im ton und die strategische
partnerschaft zwischen russland und
china noch mal betont hat und da geht es
in der tat genau darum sozusagen
gegenüber dem westen seinen konzepten
seinen ideen von von internationaler
ordnung ein gegenmodell
aufzustellen und das zu propagieren und
da eine partnerschaft zu deklarieren die
eben keine grenzen hat so wurde das in
peking formuliert und sicherlich bevor
all diesen sanktionen vor all diesen
sanktionen und sicherlich wird in peking
jetzt auch überdacht werden ob das
strategisch klug war an der stelle
sozusagen sich so weit aus dem fenster
zu lehnen grundsatz was die und das
paradigma die perspektive pekings auf
die weltlage angeht gibt es da eine
kontinuität die auch nicht so leicht
jetzt vom tisch gewischt wird also ich
sehe da tatsächlich
in putins bemühungen pekings rückhalt zu
sichern viel mehr als nur sozusagen
jetzt
eine rhetorische erklärung sondern der
tag bayern in der praxis ist dass das
was ihm den rücken gerade frei hält aber
wäre
darin auch eine chance dass man sagt man
kann china einer werden versuchen die
alle zu überlegen wie kann man food ihn
stoppen wer kann da noch vermitteln also
gibt es da eine chance dass china das
könnte da müssen wir mal darauf schon
was hat denn china insgesamt in den
letzten jahren erfahren
vermittlungsleistungen erbracht und da
werden diplomaten recht kritisch glaube
ich das beurteilen da gab sicherlich im
einzelne beispiele wo das gelungen ist
aber
china hat ist partei
auf eine art und weise in dieser
situation indem sie sich so klar hinter
russland auch stellt dann an zentralen
stellen und in dem sie hier obwohl putin
die souveränität und kleine ja nicht nur
in frage gestellt sondern tagtäglich
verletzt
dieses prinzip so scheinheilig und fast
zynisch im aufrechterhält und peking ist
da nicht konsistent und aus meiner
perspektive kein glaubhafter vermittler
ob sie in der jetzigen situation
überhaupt auf putin einwirken könnte
mitten in diesem gefecht irgendwo einen
bunker in rural wahrscheinlich gerade
steht das wage ich auch zu bezweifeln
herr goldmann sie haben putin auch
persönlich kennengelernt er wohl jemals
was glauben sie was könnte noch oder wer
und könnte noch einfluss nehmen auf
putin in dieser situation
es geht waren touristen das geht genau
so in china ob das ich kenne ich dass
der hintergrund dessen was sind die
chinesische adressen und wie entwickeln
die sich weiter in einer situation
es wird der konflikt eskalieren
ja ich habe ihn erlebt sortiert sind in
einem vierstündigen treffen mit unserem
präsidenten der nicht begleiten konnte
was mir aufgefallen ist und zwei dem
einsatz dass er besser zum war von der
idee der
ukraine als teil des erstens der dann
bedrohlich wird und dann natürlich
generell die frage der rathausverwaltung
das ist natürlich im rahmen dieser
demütigung des der niederlage im kalten
krieg des soester auflösung sollte man
ganz entscheidend jetzt kommt aber noch
etwas hinzu und darüber haben wir nicht
gesprochen nämlich die frage was
passiert eigentlich in moskau also was
wir sehen ist eine militärische
operation die so sieht es aus ist ein
fiasko zumindest bis heute also da gab
es ja schon propaganda über nach drei
tagen den sieg erklären könnte und da
passiert nichts und je länger sich das
hinzieht desto schwieriger wird ist und
dazu kommen noch die wirtschaft die
wirtschaftlichen situationen für putin
und was china betrifft ich weiß nicht ob
es so sehr mit den resten der eliten in
russland ist dass russland sich in die
arme und eine riesige abhängigkeit von
china bewegt also alles was man
überhaupt geht schlecht aus für gute und
die gefahr dass der realität schon
verloren hat denn das war ja vielleicht
rational rational zu drohen um etwas
rauszuholen etwas anderes ist okay jetzt
überfallen und dort hört die
nationalität auch und dann wird es
äußerst gefährlich mit den worten ich
weiß nicht was passiert aber die frage
ist und das wurde ja schon gesagt wenn
es gelingt den widerstand in der ukraine
so aufrecht zu erhalten dass der kreis
immer größer wird und die internationale
gemeinschaft die plötzlich wieder so
etwas wie entsteht gegen moskau sich den
diese position erstarkt wird ungemütlich
und man spricht nicht offen aber ich
meine der afghanistan-krieg über
acht jahren neun jahre mit
opfern die sich vielleicht
drei vier mal höher also tragen dass des
krieges aber
die opferzahlen ist enorm hoch das wird
zum problem und frage ob putin überlebt
könnte man die strategie nicht
das ist aber dann genau die gefahr dass
man das dann halt eben irrational
reagiert und das ist ja glaub ich genau
das wofür alle angst haben herum dass
sie sich ähnlich sehen ich wollte ja
auch noch was zu zu china sagen ich
teile diese einschätzung von herrnhut
atari ganz ganz deutlich glaube die
interpretation wie wir sie vielfach
gehört haben nach der abstimmung im
un-sicherheitsrat dass china hier nicht
mit russland gestimmt habe und sich
bereits in opposition bis hin die war
nicht nur voreilig sondern sie war
schlichtweg falsch ich glaube die
chinesische außenpolitik war ein
gewisser weise immer sehr viel ianos
conficker und man muss sich die
strategischen interessen aus sicht von
jean ping auch immer insoweit klar
machen
gerade mit blick auf taiwan oder die so
genannte lösung der taiwan frage
peking hat natürlich langfristig oder
mittelfristig auch kein strategisches
interesse daran dass russland völlig
scheitert und völlig besiegt sozusagen
aus diesem krieg irgendwie hervorgeht
denn
auch peking glaube ich hat hat
unterschätzt wie stark einerseits dieser
widerstandswillen der ukraine ist
zweitens hat man völlig glaube ich auch
unterschätzt die politische einheit der
eu und auch der nato
und in der perspektive
hat china sicherlich auch ein interesse
dass auch künftig die amerikaner
durchaus ihren europa stärker engagiert
bleiben weil es bindet ressourcen
aufmerksamkeit und auch ein teil der
amerikanischen streitkräfte weiterhin
hier in europa und damit stehen diese so
offen und weniger streitkräfte auch für
asien zur verfügung und strategische
perspektive wird laut doch mal über dich
aus den augen von ok auf wenig auf wen
setzt mal in der ukraine ist es wie
schaut man da nach china
ist das eine möglichkeit wo man sagt
dass sie könnten uns irgendwie helfen
interessanterweise werden heute nicht so
viele gespräche über mögliche
mittel sozusagen geführt es wird sehr
darauf gepocht in diese militärische
stärke der ukraine weiterhin zu
unterstützen weil ich glaube auch über
diese flugzeuge die wir jetzt
mitbekommen haben die dann auch nach aus
polen nach deutschland transportiert
wurden dass die vielleicht in richtung
ukraine fliegen würden das ist jetzt das
was für die ukraine sehr wichtig ist
weil es geht ums überleben weil die
ukraine nicht in den nächsten tagen
überleben wird gibt es dann nicht zu
verhandeln und das ist das wichtigste
was die ukraine jetzt versucht auch nach
westen zur zu kommunizieren wir brauchen
die militärische unterstützung der mit
wegen der lage sind so zu bleiben als
start und wir wollen auch uns weiterhin
entwickeln wir wollen hier gar keinen
krieg der über jahre dauern wird und ich
glaube das was viele ich ja auch so
viele experten die und der ukraine
sprechen die sagen ja noch eine woche
noch eine woche und ich glaube keiner
möchte noch irgendwie monate lang die in
den krieg haben deswegen wird heute sehr
viel darauf gehofft auch dass der westen
durch verschiedene möglichkeiten
verschiedene wege die ukraine
militärische unterstützung durch monika
munition oder raketenabwehrsysteme oder
militärflugzeuge es wird immer gefordert
dass man die flugverbotszone dort
bewahren soll aber das wäre ja ein sehr
starker eingriff
ich vertrete so manchmal oder ich bin so
der meinung wir denken sehr oft in
diesem konzept nun nato und russland ich
bin gespannt was die kollegen jetzt dazu
sagen aber ich habe das gefühl wir haben
den konflikt zwischen dem westen und
einem autoritären system und wir sind
mittendrin in diesem konflikt
und wir versuchen einfach uns davon
zurückzuhalten und zu sagen das betrifft
uns nicht aber das betrifft uns und wir
haben auch jetzt zu tun mit mit hybriden
bedrohungen und ich finde gehe als
westen müssen auch hybride antworten
darauf liefern und nicht immer irgendwie
mit
mit unseren so antworten arbeiten die
wir aus der geschichte kennen das ist
eine herausforderung die man wenn sie
das trommeln nix sagt und wir haben
jetzt eben die nachricht dass polen eben
flugzeuge nach ramstein schickt in die
hände der usd den usa übergibt damit die
dann in die ukraine geschickt werden
können also wie groß ist denn dann die
gefahr dass letztendlich doch dass
dieser konflikt sich ausweitet und auch
in die richtung der nato dass die nato
eingreifen muss und das ist dann eben
ein viel größerer konflikt ist in denen
das will man ja so verhindern
die gefahr besteht werde ich immer abend
die nuklear enthemmung von gute live
gesehen haben in seinen ankündigungen
das ist natürlich gefährlich nicht mehr
prinzipiell müssen wir die klare
unterscheidung treffen zwischen einem
direkten eingreifen der nato in den
krieg und das wären eine flugverbotszone
denn es geht nicht um das verbot soll
die durchsetzung die durchsetzung ist
nur möglich mit der luftwaffe bedeutet
die luft kennt die russische luftwaffe
das ist eine konfrontation nato gegen
russland und dann hätte man die as
création etwas anderes ist es auch an
daten liefert auch ein flugzeug ist eine
waffe die geliefert wird jetzt kann man
sagen ist gefährlich sei natürlich das
ist alles gefährlich aber in der
jetzigen situation das finde ich richtig
unentschieden auch in der bundesrepublik
waffen zu liefern
ob das nun station sind oder ob das 50
sind oder panzer werk an und spielt an
sich keine rolle von der qualität her
wichtig ist es dass gerade gesagt worden
ist zu hoffen dass der konflikt auf
seiten der ukrainer noch gehalten werden
kann bis irgendwie die dynamik in moskau
die spielräume möglicher
effektivität nicht möglicher
positionsänderung in moskau einleiten
kann und da kommt noch etwas hinzu was
noch nicht erwähnt werden dass die
russische armee ist ein
organisatorisches chaos also wenn man da
genau geschaut hat was passiert ist sind
offensichtlich große
kommunikationsschwierigkeiten entstanden
das heißt dass die beiden städten nicht
recht kommunizieren konnten miteinander
das birgt auch gefahren in sich und ich
glaube mit der mit diesen humanitären
korridoren die zum teil die regel und
verletzt worden ist das kann sie und
damit zusammenhängen dass die gar nicht
die kommandogewalt haben und von oben
nach unten durchzugreifen herum mach was
würden sie dann setzen wenn sie das
hören was frau melnik gesagt hat wie
sehr die ukraine auf die militärische
hilfe hoffen wir konzentrieren uns ja
dann doch immer noch sehr auf die
sanktionen haben jetzt auch im
energiebereich also wie kann wie kann
das aussehen denn ganz konkret auch in
den nächsten tagen
also was wir gelernt haben und das ist
ja nicht nur in diesem konflikt können
wir das sehen sondern auch in vielen
anderen
ist das der westen im wesentlichen durch
die ereignisse ja getrieben ist
und haben ständig fast täglich unsere
positionen verändert in einer weise wie
das vielleicht vor drei wochen völlig
undenkbar gewesen ist stehe denke nur an
die diskussion mit den waffenlieferungen
aber die gefahr dass die nato natürlich
stärker hier mit hineingezogen wird die
wächst natürlich
und nochmals auch wenn das deutschland
hört aber der georgien krieg ist eben
nur durch eine massive militärische
drohungen der usa beendet worden trotz
einer gleichsam
erhöhungen der nuklear der der erhöhung
der in alarmbereitschaft in den nokia
streitkräfte auf seinen seiten russlands
die gefahr ist in der tat dass wir
hineingezogen werden langsam in diesem
konflikt ohne wirklich konkret selber
darauf
vorbereitet zu sein eine konkrete
strategie zu haben wie wir dann
militärische zwischenfälle auf
verhindern können und anderes mehr und
deswegen nimmt diese gefahr natürlich
tendenziell zu auf der anderen seite
muss man sich natürlich fragen wie lang
sieht man dieser eskalation zu mit dem
immer mehr auch zivilisten getötet
werden
man muss ja wirklich sagen dann auch
abgeschlachtet werden ohne dass sie auch
aus reinen verteidigungsmittel haben und
wenn tief eingeschlossen wird scharf
eingeschlossen wird dann ist eine
versorgung von außen über den landweg
nicht mehr möglich über den luftraum
augen moment wie nicht zu sprechen und
mittelfristig wird werden die
kampfflugzeuge vielleicht jetzt
bereitgestellt werden etwas helfen
vielleicht für paar tage aber sie werden
an der prinzipiellen luftüberlegenheit
der russischen streitkräfte solange
nichts ändern können solange nicht auch
die nato tatsächlich dort eingreifen
würde
was erwarten sie da und wo setzen würden
sie dem zustimmen das freilich wird das
ist eben wichtig ist dass die
militärische hilfe der verstärkt wird
oder sagen sie diese sanktionen werden
so stark sein gerade auch dass man das
sich dass ein umdenken geben könnte man
das ist die hoffnung dass das jetzt
natürlich schnell genug geht ich glaube
da setzen alle moment noch drauf
gleichzeitig ist es glaube ich auch
richtig dass jetzt parallel solche
schritte unternommen werden wie die
jetzt von polen
norman worden sind das zeigt aber auch
dass die zögerliche haltung der
bundesregierung hier dass wir sozusagen
in polen die führungsrolle gerade haben
und das zusammenspiel da eben der der
nato-partner usa
und warschau ist glaube ich zentral an
der stelle und ich kann das völlig
nachvollziehen dass vielleicht in berlin
und paris der fokus hier auf diplomatie
und verständigung und mögliche auswege
auch gesetzt wird gleichzeitig sind es
eben unsere hausaufgaben sind auf die
hauser firmen in berlin das ist das was
bei uns an steht und wir haben die
verantwortung dafür
also insofern ich denke wir in den
nächsten tagen wochen dazu kommen auch
aus deutscher perspektive noch viel mehr
tun zu müssen und da kommt dann ganz
konkret beispielsweise die frage der
sanktionen der importstopp in den raum
das scheint sich jetzt vielleicht auch
aufzulösen wenn das tatsächlich aus
moskau selbst direkt veranlasst wird so
wie es in den letzten stunden zu hören
ist also insofern eine sehr dynamische
situation ich denke die verantwortung
muss in berlin und paris noch viel
stärker wahrgenommen werden frage was
erwarten sie davon berlin
ja dass wir nicht mehr reagieren ich
glaube deutschland hat schon einen sehr
großen schritt jetzt gemacht ich glaube
das war vor ein paar wochen noch nicht
denkbar dass deutschland bildet er die
waffen an die unternehmen liefern wird
ich kann auch nachvollziehen dass für
deutschland als sehr schwierig ist weil
einerseits
ist deutschland mit diesem konflikt
konfrontiert und jetzt müssen auch
lösungen gefunden werden andererseits
muss auch deutschland die eigene
außenpolitik jetzt überdenken und auch
mit blick auf die ihr wirtschaft ich
glaube da was wir erleben werden in
zukunft das wir ja nicht einfach so ein
business as usual drei betreiben können
dass unsere wirtschaft aus werther
basierend sein sollen das ist viele der
wired hat ihren preis hat präsident
beiden heute gesagt also mit blick auf
die steigenden energiekosten wir merken
das wenn wir an der tankstelle vorbei
fahren dass die über zwei euro kostet
der liter benzin also wo aber jetzt
natürlich vielleicht auch viele menschen
bereit sind einen preis zu zahlen weil
sie das leid auch in der ukraine
verhindern wollen und es geht nicht nur
um leid in der ukraine stellen wir uns
vor dass jedem trainer wird ich weiß
nicht wenn ich den widerstand leisten
dann haben wir ein land der mit diesem
konflikt an zu tun haben wird was werden
wir mit einem land in europa tun ich
glaube dass es nicht das erste land der
dann fallen wird wir werden dann
bestimmt andere staaten an drei haben
und wir was wir sehen dass russland sehr
gut in der desinformation ist und jetzt
versucht auch diese diese information in
der ukraine zu verbreiten und eigentlich
hat russland eine parallele welt in
russland geschaffen die menschen wenn
sie soldaten anrufen ihre soldaten mit
ihren söhnen sprechen und die sind sagen
wir bitte hört mit diesem krieg auf in
russland und in die mütter sagen einige
du stimmst du aber für meine heimat das
ist nicht normal und ich glaube diese
diese information wird überall auch hier
verbreitet und irgendwie und zuerst ist
die ukraine anderer und dann werden die
anderen staaten fahren und ich glaube
diese realität müssen wir einfach
akzeptieren
wir sind mittendrin in conflict wer sich
schon da ende wenn das so ist herr
coleman wie frau melnik das beschreibt
müssten wir dann nicht eben nicht immer
nur reagieren also erst die waffen
liefern wenn es eigentlich fast zu spät
ist wenn man sie fast nicht mehr
hinbekommt und jetzt auch eigentlich
knallhart sagen wir müssen jetzt auch
auf gas und öl aus russland verzichten
weil das tun wir ja im moment noch nicht
ich meine dass man auch diesen immerhin
für die meisten war ein angriff reagiert
nicht agiert hat das stinkt aber man hat
reagiert und hat enorm schnell reagiert
hat massive wird und wenn heute auch
schon diskutiert wird wie wäre es denn
wenn man auch auf das gas verzichtet
kommt das sind planungen im gange wo man
sich überlegen kann was sind die folgen
für die deutsche wirtschaft
sind die folgen für den deutschen
bevölkerung in sicherheit wächst auch
die bereitschaft die opferbereitschaft
in der bevölkerung man sieht auch die
gleiche reaktion könnte außen den
wirtschaftssektor also ich finde nicht
dass man sagten untersucht
wirtschaftlich gut die wie die runden zu
kommen und macht zu wenig ich glaube da
wird noch einiges passieren was jetzt im
moment vorbereitet wird und man kann
nicht erwarten dass es so schnell
passiert also ich sehe auch nicht den
großen unterschied zwischen dem was in
deutschland passiert was in amerika
passiert es stimmt bezüglich des öls ist
von amerika jetzt sein schritt vorwärts
gemacht worden nur kostet der für
amerika zwar viel aber lange nicht so
viel wie ein importstopp des gases in
deutschland über den jetzt auch
nachgedacht wird herum macht die
leopoldina die wissenschaftler der
leopoldina haben gesagt wir können sehr
gut ohne das russische gas wir schaffen
das das wäre möglich wie sehen sie es
wäre es sinnvoll oder erwarten sie ist
das jetzt wenn der krieg so brutal
weitergeht dass deutschland auch so
schnell ähnlich wie die usa sagt wir
verzichten auf die lieferungen der
energie aus russland
also zunächst nur dann muss man ja sagen
baut sind ja die gasspeicher schon seit
letzten sommer von russland nicht mehr
aufgefüllt worden und das hat uns in
eine lage gesetz ende letzten jahres
wo die gasspeicher auf einem niveau
gefallen sind wo man angst haben musste
dass wir in europa auch in deutschland
überhaupt über diesen winter kommen das
alles sind im wesentlichen
tatsächlich von dem wetter ab nämlich
wie kalt wird es dann hätten wir einen
ungewöhnlich kalten winter hier in
europa gab mit einer sehr viel höheren
kasten nachfrage hätten wir einen sehr
viel kälteren wintern asien gehabt dann
wäre ein recruiting eine umkehr der
flüssiggas exporte richtung asien die
dann umgeleitet worden sind nach europa
ab dezember dann wäre das gar nicht erst
möglich gewesen und da muss man sich
schon fragen wie steht es mit der
deutschen versorgungssicherheit wer ist
dafür verantwortlich
etwas was offensichtlich auch ein hp
ziemlich überrascht hat auch in bezug
auf die problematik der gasspeicher das
soll jetzt alles geändert werden im
moment sieht es danach aus sagte mir ja
einen relativ milden winter bis dato
hatten und wir jetzt in die periode des
frühjahrs kommt muss wärmer wird
wo der heizbedarf dementsprechend auch
geringer wird dass wir wahrscheinlich
bis zum sommer gut durchkommen dann
müssen aber die gasspeicher wieder
aufgefüllt werden damit wir sozusagen
über den nächsten winter kommen und da
sind wir sicherlich in soweit
vorbereitet dass es intensive gespräche
der kommission der bundesregierung aber
auch der amerikaner den letzten wochen
gezeigt dass wir sicherlich vielleicht
die hälfte des russischen gases ganz gut
ersetzen könnten auch über den winter
hinweg aber sicherlich nicht 170
milliarden kubikmeter auf einen schlag
die europäische kommission bemüht sich
gerade eine strategie auszuarbeiten die
dem ist bekannt werden soll dass man
zwei drittel des russischen der
russischen gaslieferungen in diesem
umfang von 170 milliarden kubikmeter
ersetzen kann durch eine vielzahl von
maßnahmen das wird glaube ich relativ
schwierig aber fakt ist über den
nächsten winter ist eine komplette
ersetzung des russischen gases in diesem
umfang so nicht möglich das heißt da er
zeigt während das heißt ja dann das ist
dann immer noch die macht russlands und
gibt russland immer noch geld auch für
die kriegskasse
das ist er dann genau also selbst kennen
wenn russland weniger gas liefert für
das ja zu einer situation dass ein
bieterwettstreit stattfindet auf den
globalen gasmärkten richtung flüssiggas
wenn dann flüssiggas nach europa
umgeleitet wird dann haben wir dafür
mehr geld geboten das heißt diese
flüssiggas exporte kommen dann in
anderen ländern nicht an obwohl die
ursprünglich war verträge unterzeichnet
haben aber es führt auch bei uns dazu
dass das natürlich extrem teuer wird ja
und der hat russland mit weniger
gasexporten sehr viel mehr geld
sozusagen generieren auf der basis sehr
viel höhere gaspreise selbst über den
stand von heute 1 hinaus ok so dass die
verluste für die russische seite nicht
so groß nicht so gross hatte das bleibt
ein großes problem ich würd gerne die
letzten minuten nochmals um einen
kleinen ausblick zu wagen
wie beobachten sie das was denken sie
wie sich das entwickelt wird auch
nochmal mit dem mit dem blick auf china
wenn man jetzt sieht dass sich dadurch
sozusagen
wenn die ukraine die ja in die eu will
auch in antrag gestellt hat dass er die
eu vielleicht dadurch auch mächtiger
würde also auch so eine längere sicht
also was würde das bedeuten für die
weltordnung und so würde sich china da
einsortieren peking wird in den nächsten
wochen erstmal sehr kalibriert fahren
ich glaube die grundlinie ist klar
nämlich russland nicht in den rücken zu
fallen und sozusagen eine
rettungsweste
auszuhändigen und dann wo es möglich ist
russland an der seite zu stehen
gleichzeitig werden sie versuchen den
schaden in dem verhältnis zum besten so
weit wie möglich zu minimieren den
besten tag sie brauchen dann besten sie
brauchen dann funktionieren die globale
wirtschaft sie sind sehr abhängig davon
versuchen das natürlich dramatisch zu
reduzieren
ich glaube im kern wird werden die
entwicklungen jetzt erst mal die sorgen
in peking gehörte nämlich die sorgen vor
einem etwas geschlossenen westen die
sorgen vor dem was an wirtschaftlichen
druck entsteht in peking die sorgen
dafür auch was es bedeutet dass
tatsächlich so ein militärischer
konflikt regional begrenzt
eben nicht bleibt sondern dass
tatsächlich dann die usa und andere
staaten sich einmischen das wird
natürlich mit blick auf teil man sehr
genau beobachtet und
die handlungsfähigkeit der europäischen
union das ist etwas was päckchen
überraschte da wird sehr genau
nachgefragt was ist denn mit der
deutschen außenpolitik jetzt los was
bedeutet dass mit blick auf die
verteidigungsfähigkeit da sollten jetzt
stand jetzt wahrscheinlich selbst nicht
überschätzen und
guldimann was ist denn ihre hoffnung
wenn wir hören am donnerstag gibt es
weitere gespräche zwischen den
außenministern ukraine und russlands
also welche hoffnung haben sie da oder
wie schätzen sie die nächsten tage
wochen ein
nochmals ich halte nichts von diesen
gesprächen solange es keinerlei
anzeichen gibt es juristische position
sich verändert darum ist möglich dass
man über um einen korridor spricht dass
es hier wichtigen gut für die menschen
aber das heißt überhaupt nicht dass das
friedensgespräche sind dass man hier
sich vorstellen könnte dass wir zu einer
lösung
das zweite ist die frage ja wir
diskutieren jetzt das ist eine sehr
realistische annahme von der stabilität
der regierung in moskau ausgehend
möglich dass das so ist vielleicht
verändert sich da was ich glaube das ist
ziemlich offen sondern auch wenn das in
dieser art jetzt so schlecht für die
russische invasion
militärisch geht wie in den letzten zwei
wochen und das trägt er einfach noch
eine klammer was mich überrascht hat ist
wir haben fast keine seilbahn treffe
gesehen man hat über jahre hinweg
bedroht die angst gehabt vom wenn der
nächste krieg passiert dann gibt es
große selber aktive gegen das wahlamt
zumindest in der öffentlichkeit relativ
wenig bekannte angriffe die sicher nicht
die haupt entwicklung des konfliktes
stadt beantragt herum was ihr schütteln
den kopf noch ist ganz kurz dazu zu den
cyberangriffen war das eher
kopfschütteln ja
auch
also man muss schon sehen erstmal war
die ukraine selbst das testfeld für
starts unterstützte cyberangriffe
russland sie erinnert an russland oder
in die ukraine war 2015 von diesem
ersten staatlich unterstützten
cyberangriff den so haupt weltweit gab
massiv betroffen damit sind nun mal auch
eine signalwirkung nicht nur naiv
sondern seinerzeit eben auch an den
westen man hat also konkret ja die
stromzufuhr die wie ich die stromnetze
angegriffen
herum machen da wir fast am ende der
sendung sind hoffen wir dass nicht immer
die nächsten den rückweg werden da ganz
kurz nur einfach nur
haben sie noch hoffnung für die nächsten
tage
nein für die nächsten tage habe ich muss
ich gestehen wenig hoffnung ich glaube
die frau wenig dass es eben nicht nur
allein um die fragen der nato
osterweiterung geht sondern wir haben
hier einen wirklichen
systemkonflikt den man eigentlich seit
2005 schon sehen konnte weil seit der
orangenen revolution 2005 und deshalb
putin teilweise klar erkennen lassen war
eine neutralität der ukraine für ihn nur
vorstellbar wenn sie auf dauer durch
einen vasallen regime durch eine nicht
demokratische regierung die von moskau
kontrolliert wird diese neutralität
gesichert werden konnten und deswegen
ging das weit über die nato
osterweiterung hinaus und der grimm
konfliktes nicht wegen der nato
osterweiterung seiner zeit entstanden
sondern es war die perspektive um eine
eu-mitgliedschaft ok frau melnik
trotzdem am sie noch die letzte frage ob
es eine hoffnung gibt sie haben am
anfang gesagt die ukraine als stärker
als wir gedacht haben das so ist es und
ich hoffe sehr dass der westen sich
nicht einschüchtern lässt weil wir haben
auch zu tun mit einer hybriden
kriegs mit einer hybriden kriegsführung
desinformations spielt hier schon eine
rolle und dass wir weiterhin so einig
bleiben weil das stimmt der westen ist
aus dem würde ich schon jetzt hat darauf
reagiert aber wir müssen einfach einen
langen atem haben und die konflikte und
die ukraine nicht alleine lassen und die
menschen in der ukraine müssen einen
langen atem haben und das ist natürlich
sehr bitter für die menschen die noch
dort sind vielen dank ihnen frau wenig
guldimann herum bach und vorher uhr der
hutaree tschuldigung vielen dank fürs
zuschauen morgen beschäftigen wir uns
wieder mit dem konflikte mit den kriegen
der ukraine und dann schauen wir aber
mal auf die bundeswehr 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr ist es jetzt ein
ausweg oder wie manche auch sagen ein
irrweg seien sie wieder dabei wir freuen
uns jetzt geht es weiter mit phoenix der
tag mit thomas bade bis dann tschüss